[Music]
if you're a NGO developer you're
probably excited about going 11 but you
might also be wondering does App Engine
support the new runtime can I write
idiomatic go and run it on App Engine
and if you're writing go for the cloud
the last thing you want to do is worry
about maintaining and deploying
infrastructure App Engine Google's
platform as-a-service handles all that
for you so you can focus on what's
important writing go code let's show
them how we're gonna show you how to
deploy a go application to App Engine
using the new go 111 runtime now with
the new go 111 runtime it's incredibly
easy to write idiomatic go code and
deploy it to App Engine all you need are
three things your go code a yamo file
that describes your runtime and the
vendor directory with your dependencies
let's take a look at each one first
we'll write a small HTTP server that
listens on port 8080 and responds with
hello world to all requests our code is
idiomatic and totally unconcerned with
the underlying infrastructure next we
need to specify the runtime we want for
our app so in the root of our project
and an app yamo file with just one line
in it go 111 and finally here's our file
structure with a vendor directory we're
using go support for vendor in our
dependencies which the new runtime
supports out of the box also if you're
interested in trying out go support for
modules the runtime supports that as
well now that we finished writing our
app let's deploy it it takes only one
command g-cloud app deploy let's start
the timer while we're waiting for the
app to deploy let's talk about what
makes App Engine a great choice for go
applications first the new go runtime
not only does it have first-class
support for mentoring it also supports
go modules you can use any library or
framework that makes sense for your
application all while running that
familiar ami go code that all Gophers
love and you get the benefits of Google
App Engine standard environment
things like fast deployments building in
the cloud manage security updates
support for HTTP scaling to zero when
the app is idle in addition to logging
met
tricks and error reporting and with that
app as a point there is we're both
really excited about the new runtime and
we hope you are too
I'm you know Compton and I'm Angela funk
feel free to leave questions or comments
in the section below reach out to us on
Twitter and don't forget to subscribe to
the Google cloud platform YouTube
channel for more go videos thanks for
watching